[Music]
bella bella is a fishing village on bc's
central coast
here life and livelihood have always
depended on the sea
the only way in or out is by boat or
plane
[Music]
we're here as guests of the healthsuc
nation our guide is frank brown a
hereditary chief
my healthstock name is gladlyasila
i serve as a senior advisor to the
indigenous leadership initiative
he's guiding us inside the territory of
his people which lies in the heart
of the great bear rainforest
[Music]
this is the largest remaining tract of
temperate coastal rainforest where the
life of land and sea meet
like few places on earth
[Music]
our first stop is the bella bella
hatchery part of an effort to boost
salmon populations
at one time a hudson's bay fur trading
post stood nearby but it has long since
disappeared enveloped by the surrounding
forest
[Music]
along the creek sea otters race by
the voracious fur trade nearly brought
them to the brink
they've since made a comeback i think we
can find out a little bit more over time
you know but for the salmon it's a
different story
this pond here would be full of salmon
so you wouldn't have to go very far like
many here kelly brown has childhood
memories of better days when the creeks
and rivers teemed with salmon
he's the director of the heltzook
integrated resource management
department pacific salmon have been in
decline for decades and in recent years
they witnessed a sudden and profound
event
what happened eight years ago in 2014
we're not sure what happened
but the salmon return collapsed even in
this
salmon enhancement program
and that happened for every system
throughout our territory
and so something phenomenal happened in
the ocean
brown oversees the guardians who monitor
salmon across their territory
we have guardian watchmen that will come
into every salmon system
bearing stream that we have
ones that aren't burying that normally
would be bearing and see whether or not
there's salmon
running in those systems to
inform
whether or not we're
comfortable with opening up a commercial
fishery or even a food fishery for
people
it would have been nice to have
our grandchildren here to be able to be
fishing the food
for
the community
and
we're hardly even able to do that now
across the channel deeper into the
rainforest is kunsut
it means place of many salmon
here we find josh vickers
waiting among the spawning beds
we have pinks in here we have cows in
here
we have sockeye and a little bit of chum
so far
he's one of a team of guardians
monitoring the salmon run
he just counted 1 000 pink salmon in the
estuary
not bad but still far from what it was
before
i'm happy to see this but historically
there was a lot more
he and other guardians are carrying out
the vital field work that combines
science with traditional knowledge
measuring water quality and temperature
and salinity
[Music]
counting and tracking the migration of
each salmon species
gathering key information needed to plan
for next year's fishing season
[Music]
hang on i'll grab that
yeah it gets colder
right now we're uh in peak sound peak
spawning season
yeah it's gonna be a little a little bit
of a slick so just watch yourself when
we're up here creek walking what we're
looking for is
live salmon and dead salmon and what
species are
at what place in previous years what
would we see here so like now we see
maybe about 7 000 pinks
whereas before they saw like 700 000.
[Music]
using ingenuity to manage salmon has
deep roots here
on their way home the guardians pass
this ancient salmon trap one of many
engineered long ago to harness the tides
this time of year
[Music]
we traveled according to the seasons
starting with a herring
and then we would move into salmon and
bottom fish and we moved all throughout
our entire territory
as marine agriculturalists they tended
to the sea that in turn tended to them
there were
many many
villages
throughout our whole territory and
almost every river system
in our territory
was utilized by our people but when the
newcomers arrived they put us on these
little plots of land
known as indian reserves
colonialism brought catastrophe here
there is a premeditated plan to sever
our relationship from the land
so that they could get access to the
resources in the bounty of the land and
the sea
at contact the heltsuk numbered upwards
of 20 000 people across 50 villages
then came harrowing waves of smallpox
and influenza
their people were brought to the brink
at one point fewer than 200 remained
the horrors and injustices of the
colonial era continued residential
schools the loss of the big house the
banning of the potlatch
their culture and language forced
underground the cornerstone of this our
society is the potlatch system and that
was our system of governance and how
resources and wealth was redistributed
through the community the idea to
separate us from our place was
devastating it's created all kinds of
social issues
health issues
mental health issues and even impacting
our spirits
[Music]
many of the old villages have faded into
the landscape but there are signs of
renewal
in bella bella a landmark of the past
has been restored to life
this is the big house the heart of the
community
it's the home of the potlatch and a
place of gathering that was destroyed in
the colonial era
there's a lot of intergenerational pain
and there's a lot of intergenerational
brilliance
over a decade in a making these
form-line house posts were painstakingly
designed carved and painted and tell of
the deep origins and resilience of a
people
chief frank's daughter gottawas is
withheld took climate action she says
the strength of the future draws from
the well of the past
we're working really hard to
connect all those dots back good morning
those innate values she says empower her
people to fight climate change we're
really calling on our um
our ancestors so that we're in alignment
with our goylas with our heel strike
laws and ways of existing in
relationship with the land and with the
water and so i see there's a lot of
opportunity
with climate action
to tie in
all of our teachings because really it's
about that original existence
indigenous guardians are both old and
new the formal network has only been
around for about five years but their
connection to the land goes back
hundreds of generations indigenous
people have monitored managed and cared
for the land in the sea for thousands of
years living sustainably the guardian
program operated now is funded by the
federal government and each of the 70
guardian programs is established and run
locally as distinct as the first nations
they represent and the issues they face
and the effects of climate change are
being felt everywhere they work
including on canada's east coast
as dawn arrives in unemagi land of the
fog
a rite of fall is underway
the annual moose harvest for the migma
in the highlands of cape breton nova
scotia adjust your seat if you like
guides are keith christmas
and as we were driving in i just kept
checking the tree line tree line and
nothing and clifford paul
both are from the unemagi institute of
natural resources
when you drive in you're looking for
heads
over years they're taking us on a trek
up these muddy logging roads into the
boreal forest
and keep britain's
[Music]
see a dark spot there but that's not a
moose
it requires patience moose are elusive
by nature
it's pretty deceiving some of these uh
spots out there
but the signs are there if you know
where to look
that's why you see a lot of droppings
here you tell where they were eating too
how can they go
cause they're eating these tips oh
they'll eat the fresh yeah they're
eating these tips here
just as the buffalo is important to the
plains indians so is
the moose to the migma clifford has to
contend with a different kind of
conservation problem how many moose
would be
in the highlands here do you think the
last estimate was 2400 give or take so
from an enigma perspective a healthy
herd is dependent on a healthy ecosystem
so 2400 we think it's good because the
carrying capacity
of the ecosystem serves the population
better than having a hyper-abundant
population moose weren't always so
abundant a century ago the population
was wiped out another species from
alberta was introduced and with no
natural predators left it flourished so
today in the absence of wolves in
unemagi in nova scotia what's going to
keep the population in check is the
humans the human human interaction
[Music]
without hunting moose would overrun the
highlands and over feed on the saplings
that regenerate the boreal forest
traditionally the migma would head
inland to hunt this time of year a way
of life disrupted by colonialism i have
the right to do this
but more importantly have the
responsibility and the migma fought so
hard for those rights they fought
incredibly hard for those rights
and how many were in your hunting party
that's where the guardians come in
hannah martin is with the confederacy of
mainland migma
it's a really important time for us as
migma people to be on the land here in
unamagi and
harvesting this resource it's more than
just a harvest it's everything for us
when a moose is harvested the antlers
are measured samples are collected
details from the hunters are recorded
all vital information to track and
monitor the health of the population we
really treat the moose the salmon
everything with respect and with honor
down from the highlands and along the
sweeping coast of cape breton
our guides lead us to a sacred place
this place has uh much uh spiritual
significance we're surrounded by rock
the rocks are the grandfathers they're
the keepers of the stories talked along
these limestone cliffs is glooscop's
cave for the megma this is the center of
the universe
the stories the landscape the seascape
the legends they all come together here
it's a place of healing and renewal
where clifford acts as a guide leading
tracks by land sharing a golden moment
of his first experience here when i
showed up i couldn't believe the
the light that was shining through me
the spiritual connection the whole cape
is now an indigenous protected and
conserved area
[Music]
albert marshall a revered migma elder
joins us on the trip
this is his first visit to the cave in
decades and his mind turns to the
troubles of the present what have we
done to this very source of life in
which we all depend upon even as we
speak water and air and soil
has no protection whatsoever
it is considered a commodity in the
mi'kmaq language the duty to live
sustainably is captured in one word
neduco lymph
is actually a
guiding principle as to how
we go through life nature has rights
humans have responsibility and that is
something i believe and i totally
honestly and believe that it's very much
inherent in the aboriginal ways of
thinking with all the knowledge that we
have we are drowning in all this
knowledge
but i think in fact we are starving in
wisdom if we are starving in wisdom
what can
non-indigenous people learn from your
ancestral
knowledge of the land if a group of
people in this hemisphere
for thousands and thousands and
thousands of years
can coexist in harmony with nature
shouldn't we shouldn't we be smart
enough to think there's got to be some
lessons in there
a view of the world that animates first
peoples across the continent from
unamagi to the great bear rainforest
and throughout the depth of history here
in heltzig territory
these channels and inlets harbor
countless memories of those who came
before like these figures carved in
stone
we
now know that our people have been here
for the last
700
generations or over 14 000 years
oral traditions tell of a place where
long ago the heltzik found refuge beyond
the reach of the ice
my uncle told me that that's where our
people originally came from
those stories drew a team of
archaeologists from the hakai institute
and the university of victoria to
trickett island in 2017
there they unearthed one of the oldest
settlements ever discovered in the
americas dating back to the last ice age
artifacts suggest those here were highly
skilled hunters of sea mammals who later
turned to fishing
and adept and adaptable people who
survived and thrived in the extremes of
time
and among the oldest finds the charred
remnants of a fourteen thousand year old
hearth
and a fire that burned so long ago
we've waited a long time
to see this happen
this is our sacred house
a house of honor
in 2019 the helchick opened their big
house
the first on their territory in more
than 120 years
a shining moment in a cultural revival
we are a resilient people we did stand
on the abyss of near extinction and an
annihilation but our generations now are
the ones that are
gaining strength it's through our young
people
that are students of the culture
working with our elders and our
knowledge keepers that are
leading the way
we will continue to exist on our lands
for the next 14 000 years
i believe
that we as a native people of this land
have been the voice of reason
around the
devastation of natural resources it
really goes down to values